haut
et je le veux
dire
Tout est laissé pour vous, puisqu'il y avait déjà
arnaqué
mon coeur demande un mensonge pour attendre
ta blessure impossible
je ne veux pas
l'aime plus
chaud
dans ma longue nuit à montero ne meurt pas
le cauchemar de seulement
dans l'ombre douloureuse de ton choix
dans leur sillage qu'ils ne reviendront peut-être pas
il me semble parfois qu'ils ont
rêves
ajouter que puis entier
est un fantôme à aimer avec illusion
et il reste de son avis qu'il quittait son
vision
Séville
bleu
il
argent
quelques heures qui meurent refusent de
passer il y a un défilé de personnages étranges
qui me regarde comme
l'infini qui est dans l'oubli
consommation
la bouche était la mienne maintenant je n'ai que la
angoisse de mon mal
dans l'ombre lugubre du deuil j'espère
alors peut-être que ça ne reviendra pas
parfois il me semble qu'ils s'arrêtent
seul
tu es tout le jeu
la science
C'est un fantôme qui crée mon illusion
et quoi
s'estomper
laissant sa vision
mieux
Ouais